hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that comes as a suggestion
from nelson jimenez vargas
uh it's from the 2015 tata still masters
and it's magnus carlson versus 11 rnm
i don't know if it was already called
the tata still masters in 2015 because
they're they used to have the a
tournament in the b tournament
uh but yeah i guess yeah it was yeah it
was already called uh
tata still master so it's uh from round
five
uh and uh well it's uh it's a very nice
game we we haven't covered this one
because
i've been starting to cover i've started
the cover games from like 2000
2016. i do have some videos on youtube
from 2015 but those were mostly just
weird videos not like the the
the ones that i do today i'm not saying
these ones aren't weird it's just those
were
a lot weirder and uh well it's uh it's
quite the game and uh we
we will sort of get a glimpse into what
awaits nipple
in november when he will uh fight
against magnus
for the world chess championship title
so let's check it out and let's see what
makes this suggestion uh
so so special magnus has the white
pieces and he opens with
d4 we have knight to f6 by 11
c4 e6 knight to f3 and d5 so just the
normal queens gambit declined
and the uh well for the for the better
part of the opening
this would there will be nothing weird
going on knight c3 bishop to b4
uh that goes in defenses on the board we
have captures captures and now
bishop to g5 uh we have h6 uh trying to
either chase away the bishop or uh force
the bishop to trade
and here we have bishop captures and f6
queen captures
and now queen to a4 with check
connecting with the bishop so you have
to play knight to c6 to block check and
defend the bishop
uh all at once uh knight to c6 and now
e3 uh we have castles and now bishop to
e2
bishop to e6 so still nothing other out
of the ordinary here there are like
150 games with this exact same position
from
uh series tournaments uh we have castles
in then now a6
we have rook f the c1 by magnus and now
bishop back to d6 the bishop no longer
serves any purpose here
and magnus says that goes uh also for my
queen so queen back to d1
and now knight the e7 preparing to shift
the knight over to the king side and
here you might
start expanding with c6 because this
pawn might become a problem
uh later on so here we have a3 and now
rook
f2d8 we have b4 by magnus grabbing more
space on the queen side preparing ideas
like knights to a4
knight to c5 and now yeah there is one
game
where bishop to g4 was played but here
11 plays
knight to c8 and it is uh now uh
only as of move 15 that we have a
completely new game
but also a position that has never been
repeated since
this game was played so here uh magnus
goes knight to a4 he of course wants to
shift his knight
to c5 and of course um 11 prevents this
uh we have b5 uh b6 preventing the
knight from coming to c5 and now
knight to b2 the knight is now coming to
d3
and from d3 the knight will control a
lot of very very important squares
here so knight to e7 and now
knight to d3 we have knight to g6 and
now
a4 by magnus 11 plays a5 he wants the
uh uh well he he he's probably expecting
magnus to just push the pawn to b5
uh but anything other than this is just
bad for white so here
b5 uh and rook to e8 and here
it's very hard to imagine that you can
actually break through this with white
because uh
okay this is a backward spawn but as
long as this dark square bishop is
defending it doesn't matter how many
rooks you have
on the c file so let's see how magnus
goes about this we have rook to c3
and bishop to f5 now uh we have rook 8
to c1 and just
rook 8 to d8 like i said nothing matters
as long as the bishop guards the c7 pawn
we have knight to d2
maybe maybe with some ideas of pushing
some points here in the center but it's
very unlikely the queen is here the
bishop pair is here the knight is here
uh the rook might even have a way of
entering the position if this knife from
d2 ever moves
uh so it's uh basically just you know
waiting so here
rook to d7 uh if the bishop ever moves
you will have another defender here
uh we have g3 and now knight to f8 by
11.
uh we have bishop to g4 here magnus
finds a way on how to
how to at least play something and
bishop g4 is definitely playing
something
as if eleven trades then uh you can
already bring the queen over to g4
so here knight the h7 and now bishop
captures we have queen captures and
now comes queen to f3 offering a queen
trade
and uh if 11 accepts this for example
captures captures
uh then it's uh uh well it's ju
it's a fine position for both white and
black maybe a little bit easier for
white to play
but uh you know you might have uh some
problems containing the
these knights uh for example uh if if f6
uh to control the knight then you weaken
your light squares for example knight h4
now you can go to f5 or g6
so may it would be it would be a better
position for white without so many moves
for for black to play so here 11
the instead declines this he plays queen
to g5
and h4 now magnus starts chasing away
the queen
queen to e7 and now comes rook the c6
and rook the c6 is a beautiful move
uh but you will only learn this uh later
on
uh here uh i know you guys are wondering
what about the d-pawn can we capture
this
we can uh and maybe it's even playable
but uh move like bishop before let's say
goes after the rook and the queen and
now you have to give up the exchange
so maybe your your massive pawn chain
would be worth it and maybe
uh if uh the the dark square bishop is
exchanged for rook then maybe even these
spawns become
weak so maybe we could take this into
advantage
if it was a blizz game or something
probably uh definitely a playable move
uh but for uh for a classical game maybe
not so much so here
rook the c6 this is also very very
impressive as you'll see
knight to f6 and now knight to f4 by
magnus now with a double attack on this
spawn
we have g6 by 11 and now h5
asking what do you want to do here do
you want to advance the pawn
you could capture on d5 with the knight
and then for example captures captures
and captures but again we leave black
with the same option cyto bishop a3 goes
after the rook
or even bishop captures on g3 now just
opens up a discovery here
next we're going to bring back the
bishop kind of shattering white's king
side
it's similar to what happened in the
game uh so we're going to discuss it
again so here uh
like i said h5 uh and now king to g7
we have captures captures and now knight
captures and
on the e5 we have knight captures queen
captures on d5 and now
bishop captures on g3 opening up a
discovery towards uh carlson's queen
uh and the the bishop of course cannot
be captured so
queen back the g2 and this is why the
rook was so important here on c6
is now uh if the bishop moves you will
eliminate this pawn or rather if the
bishop moves anywhere from d6
but the bishop will not be able to
remain on d6 forever
so here bishop to d6 and now comes
knight to c4 and this is the good stuff
the knight is now coming to e5
and uh well it's just not easy defending
this
g6 pawn this is a big problem for
example if you try something like g5
we're just gonna eliminate
the bishop here and then we've removed
the defender of the c7 pawn so for
example
if the rook captures then you can
capture on c7 if the pawn captures then
you eliminate the b6 spawn then
everything just falls apart so instead
after knight to c4
11 tried rook to f8 and now
this is a very tricky idea it's uh the
reason why rook to f8
is uh such a such a great move is
because it
doesn't work uh there is a uh a sneaky
defensive idea behind it for example if
knight captures on d6
uh for example c captures rook captures
and b6 now rook to
f5 with the idea of winning uh the queen
or
getting some sort of a beautiful attack
but there is one very very strong
defensive move
uh that eleven might have missed when he
played rook to f8 because uh
it's because of this move and only
because of this move that
this line doesn't work this hypothetical
line so uh feel free to pause the video
and try to find
what would be white's only move in this
position
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on solving this
hypothetical line
as we don't usually have positive video
moments in hypothetical lines but this
is a nice one so i hope everyone found
it
to those of you who did congratulations
as the is rook to c5
this is the the move that prevents black
from uh
gaining equality because you covered the
g5 square
and now there's really not all that much
for you to do
and if you capture the the rook doesn't
really help because then queen captures
on g6 king h8 for example queen captures
on f5
and this is now completely winning for
white it's a better position
white has more material uh so it's
better on
on both fronts so instead after this
rook to
f8 move uh we have knight to e5
uh knights the e5 and now comes uh
bishop captures an e5 uh so you could
have captured the bishop but this also
works so knight to the e5
now comes bishop captures an e5 queen
captures on g6
and now king the h8 we have queen
captures with
czech king to g8 and then now only now d
captures an e5
and now it's not going to be easy for
black to survive all of the threats so
here
queen captures and e5 was played uh rook
to g6
with check king to f7 and now rook to c4
bringing yet another attacker into the
game uh we have queen the a5
with a queen day would check uh as the
queen defends the h8 square so maybe you
can trick uh
white into going something like king to
h2 then maybe you can trap the queen
like this
uh but uh king to g2 of course was
played and now there really isn't
anything rook to hate was played but now
rook f4 check king the e8 and now rook
to
e6 with check and now if you go to d8 is
just a very quick
win you can even sacrifice the queen
here queen checks rook captures rook
captures will be checkmate
so instead after rookies uh wrote the e6
check rook the e7 was played
but now we have captures captures and
rook to e4 check
and he was in this position on move 47
that 11 iron
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
uh uh to you know i know you guys always
want to
watch the game until the end so uh the
the simplest way to to end this would be
something like king d7 we're gonna
deliver
check and now whatever you play you're
you're getting destroyed king d8 you're
gonna play rook to d4
with check king the e7 now comes rook
the d7 check
and that's it king to e8 queen to e6
check and now let's say uh king to
f8 queen to f7 will be checkmate uh but
yeah
uh after rook to e4 uh eleven resigned
and the magnus won this game uh
in round five along with the entire
tournament so just uh so we don't forget
here are the standings uh let me just
center that a little bit yeah there we
go like this
uh uh from the 2015 tata still masters
tournament we've never covered this
tournament in its entirety but we've
covered some of the games from it as we
you know sometimes we show a game by
even charity or by
hawifan uh and uh though those were
uh some of the nicer tournaments uh uh
that uh you know uh that they played in
when they were younger
also i think lyran had a very nice very
nice tournament here
uh but yeah a lot of very strong names
here and magnus carlsen emerges
victorious half a point ahead of uh
maksim anishikiri wesley so and dingle
uh and uh let's not forget vaseline who
is
with seven out of seven and a half out
of 13 in quite a comfortable place here
a half point
ahead of fabiano corona uh but yeah
no doubt we'll be returning to this
tournament uh more and more
uh but uh for the time being uh that's
one of the games
that i decided to show you so it was a
more than a welcome suggestion
and uh we'll be going through some other
games by both
magnus and yanni pondichi to see what
are we
uh you know uh what will we see
when november comes uh so yeah uh that's
the game hope you enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank austin del rio
uh alcala
alkylani uh justin brockhouse uh
frederick rusek and akram the pilot for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage
of all of your suggestions checking up
on the morphe saga and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day